all sorts of different right-wing media
types on the internet have increasingly
been talking about a civil war a civil
war that they believe is coming and in
some sense a civil war that some of them
seem to actually be welcoming and
whether it is because of those
individuals
or for other reasons we now have two in
five americans roughly 40 percent of
americans who believe that within the
next decade there is going to be another
civil war here in the united states now
when we say civil war and united states
what we think back to is the civil war
in the united states of course in the
19th century which was a war essentially
over slavery it was between the union
and the confederacy the union which
wanted to end slavery and the
confederacy which wanted to keep it now
there's been revisionist history which
has been done
to sort of glorify the confederacy or at
least make it seem more benign and
usually the way that's done is they say
it's not about a war to keep slavery
it's a war for states rights a
fundamental conservative value and sure
if what the states wanted a right to do
was to keep slavery legal then so be it
but really it wasn't about slavery it
was about states rights now that's bs
doesn't we don't have to get into more
detail but that is the the false story
that many of those who i guess today
would still be on the side of the
confederacy uh like that's the story
they like to tell about the first civil
war and now we have an economist yougov
poll wherein 40 percent of americans
believe we are heading towards another
civil war now let's look at a couple of
the different things that are in this
poll
first and foremost
do americans expect political divisions
and violence to increase over the next
few years
and the answer is that on political
divisions
two-thirds of americans believe we will
be more politically divided
and that uh political division is likely
to increase and on political violence 65
percent believe that political violence
has increased and looking ahead 62
believe it will continue to increase now
what is the partisan split here this is
very very important for those who say
that in the last year and a half the
country has become
more divided
republicans are more likely than
independents and democrats to say that
now what has happened during that time
well a democrat joe biden became
president of the united states the mere
presence of biden they believe has made
the country more divided and if you look
at looking ahead do you think the amount
of political division is more likely to
increase stay the same or decrease it is
republicans more than democrats that
believe political division will increase
but it's not a big difference this is
actually quite interesting because it's
only a 14-point split
the country is mostly on the same page
both republicans and democrats 58
percent of democrats think there will be
more political division
and 72 percent of republicans it is a
difference but it is not a dramatic
partisan difference now
on the issue of civil war this is very
very important and disturbing take a
look at these numbers um
among adult
citizens in general
43 percent say it is very or somewhat
likely that there will be another civil
war in the next 10 years
and this is where the partisan split is
somewhat more significant
among democrats those for example who
are strong democrats
40
believe a civil war is very or somewhat
likely whereas among strong republicans
54 believe a civil war
is very or somewhat likely that is a
significant difference but also it's not
like the 70 20 type thing you know you
there are questions you can ask
people
and the partisan split is significantly
more dramatic i'm struggling to think of
which ones they would be but you know on
issues related to for example guns
sometimes you see a massive partisan
split
14 points on civil war
is not like a dramatic split
now where i believe you would see a
significant difference would be if you
ask folks
what do you believe would cause such a
civil war what do you believe would
cause such a civil war
my instinct is and this is something
that you would have to do a poll on if
you ask the left-wingers what do you
think would cause the civil war
i think most left-wingers would say
right-wingers launching a civil war
and if you asked the right-wingers what
would cause a civil war
i think they would mostly say
the left-wingers would cause a civil war
in other words i think
in different
terms
you would see both the left and the
right say that it would be the right
that would precipitate and take action
on that civil war the leftists would say
the right-wingers are going to do it
because they don't like the ways in
which society is changing and the
right-wingers would say we had no choice
because look at what the leftists were
doing to our country
very different moral frameworks in terms
of who is responsible
but i think it would be in a sense
an agreement in that it would be the
rightists who actually launch it and the
writers would say well we had no choice
because of what the leftists have done
to this country
not particularly pleasing numbers i mean
when nearly half the country thinks in
the next decade there will be a civil
war
it doesn't seem to be boding
particularly well
we're going to follow these numbers and
it would be good to have other polling
as well because it is
increasingly a topic i mean later in the
show actually
we're going to have a clip of conspiracy
theorist alex jones who just got dinged
for 49 million in a defamation suit
he seems to be trying to precipitate
that civil war and is predicting it i
think within the i think he said in 71
days oddly specific but we'll get to
that alex jones clip a little bit later
on in the show
republicans have seen the polling and
they are terrified
that running strongly against all
abortions
is going to crush them in november so we
have to understand now on the left the
republicans have have seen the polling
they know the numbers in the aftermath
of the repeal of roe v wade by the
supreme court the overturning of roe v
wade by the supreme court uh we have
seen a dramatic shift in polling for
these november midterm elections and
i've told you that we're going to look
at the numbers tomorrow or thursday but
the odds that democrats keep the senate
are now roughly two to one
democrats still
expected to lose the house but by a
smaller margin that at any point during
this midterm election cycle and much of
it much of it is because of the anger
about roe v wade being overturned and
the fundamental right to an abortion in
most cases disappearing republicans are
aware of this and we are now seeing a
number of different republicans either
in interviews or on their websites
change or certainly restructure the way
that they talk about abortion some of
them removing altogether their
anti-choice stances from their
respective websites so last week i
brought you the story of this democrat
in michigan who won in a swing district
in a special election by focusing in on
abortion just straight up one
and it's abundantly clear that this is a
big risk for republicans we now have a
clip from
this is from yesterday or maybe the day
before yet no this is from yesterday
this is john o i believe it's pronounced
od might be oh day this is the
republican senate candidate in colorado
he went on fox news
and he made it very clear he supports
women's right to choose an abortion
early in the pregnancy and even later
when there are particular circumstances
take a listen to this a very different
sounding republican
martha thanks for having me on today i
really appreciate it you know your race
was very interesting one to watch you
beat a candidate who was more of a trump
supporter you are sort of running in a
more moderate lane and yet uh your
opponent the current senator michael
bennett is is looking to sort of peg you
that way a little bit more here's an
example in an ad that dropped on friday
watch this dropped
it makes the race for senate even more
important michael bennett has always
fought to protect a woman's right to
make her own health care decisions but
joe o'day opposes the law protecting
abortion access in colorado
so we want to give you a chance to
respond to that because clearly the roe
v wade decision is becoming a factor in
races all across the country we're going
to see a lot of ads like that are they
accurately portraying your view on this
sir
oh that that adds dishonest it's at best
i came out early on in this election and
said that i supported a woman's rights
early on in the pregnancy and even later
on to you know with mitigating
circumstances so i've been very vocal
about that issue ran my primary on that
and we ended up winning um you know so
this is very interesting because
i can't tell you
that if joe o'day
makes it uh uh
makes it to the senate that he would
actually be a pro-choice vote i can't
say that what all we all we can look at
is what he's saying today
and he has made i believe the correct
calculation that at this point
when it comes to democrats
and even moderate republicans
it is not a good idea to take these
wacky anti-choice views in a state like
colorado when you're running in the
senate now
if you are running
in a particular red district
for the house
in alabama it's a very different story
but he's correctly sort of taking the
pulse of the electorate in colorado and
the pulse of the country and if he is
going to defeat bennett and get to the
senate
with that electorate and the entire
state of colorado as the voting
constituency he can't be a wacky
anti-choicer now he may be an
anti-choicer personally but he has made
the correct calculation that he can't
really be running that way this is not
super unique we're seeing instances of
this elsewhere as well in arizona four
days ago
blake masters right wing nut
backtracks on abortion and scrubs his
campaign website this is all from the
last week so blake masters realizing i
might want to ease up on some of the
anti-abortion stuff
um
another example here
republican congressional candidate and
state senator tom barrett
totally removed the value section of his
campaign website which touted his
anti-abortion position and history with
the pro-life movement also making the
calculation that listen even if these
are my views and even if this is how i'm
ultimately going to vote if the people
elect me i don't necessarily want to be
promoting this and making it front and
center this is a very important shift
now what are what are the going to be
the substantive repercussions of such
such a shift we we actually don't know
yet because part of it is
are these republicans actually becoming
mildly pro-choice or are they just lying
because they see that that's what they
need to do in order to get themselves
elected and it won't actually change
anything if and when they do
that's a it's a predictive question
we're just guessing we don't have the
answer but the fact that they're feeling
the need to change their messaging on
this issue is already extraordinarily
important let me know what you make of
this are these candidates
is there going to be a wave of
pro-choice republicans or are these
merely the lies they're willing to tell
in order to get themselves elected
because they've sort of put their finger
to the wind and feel the way that it's
blowing let me know tomorrow night 6 p.m
eastern it is finally here i know many
of you have been waiting for so long it
is the david pakman show members only
town hall we will open up the phone
lines exclusively to our members
tomorrow at 6 pm eastern every member is
welcome to participate and chat with me
it will be streaming live on youtube
twitch and facebook so everybody is free
to watch but we will just be inviting
our members to participate in the town
hall still time to sign up at join
pacman.com of our sponsors today is
ketoned we all have heard about the
ketogenic diet which puts your body in a
metabolic state of ketosis many have
reported that it's helpful for curbing
hunger or even weight loss ketoned is
the top rated ketone supplement on the
market it allows you to enjoy the
benefits without dramatically
restricting your carbs and if you
already follow a ketogenic diet ketoned
is a great way to instantly boost your
ketone levels their formula works in
under 20 minutes take ketoned advanced
blend and then test your ketone levels
and see for yourself comes in delicious
flavors like aloha punch tiger's blood
citrus mango peach and caramel macchiato
or caramel macchiato or caramel
macchiato
ketone has helped millions of people on
their keto journey since 2016. read
online what ketone customers have to say
and ketoned is giving my audience thirty
percent off plus two free bottles of
keto charged when you go to
ketoned.com
pacman and use the code pacman at
checkout
let's talk today about why right-wingers
and republicans seem to hate they really
seem furious with electric vehicles and
we've talked about this anecdotally over
the last few weeks there's been these
clips of marjorie taylor green
making completely incorrect claims about
people are being
enslaved by being forced to get electric
vehicles just completely wacky stuff but
let's actually think it through a little
bit because
when you take it at the top level
you would think that right wingers would
love electric vehicles think about it
they hate and complain all the time
about high gas prices electric vehicles
don't use gas so that would be something
that should appeal to right wingers
right wingers often have this kind of
stereotypical alpha beta male mentality
they see fast cars as indicative of
alpha male status well electric vehicles
are really fast so you'd think that
would be something that would appeal to
them they claim to like self-sufficiency
and not depending on others you can
quite literally charge your electric
vehicle at home
with solar power
harvested
from the solar panels that you own you
don't need anybody else to help you
you'd think that that would appeal to
them you don't need a gas station you
don't need a fuel tanker to deliver the
gas to the gas station
russia can't mess with gas and affect
the gas you get at the gas station think
they would love it and sort of along
that same line i mean
you could end the dependence on foreign
oil as well which is something
right-wingers claim to love
but they don't love electric vehicles in
fact they seem to hate them and it's
another one of these examples where you
have their stated principles
and then you have what's politically
convenient or inconvenient and the
reality is right wingers tend to love
oil and gas fossil fuels they see
burning fossil fuels as a good thing in
many cases
and they like angering people on the
left and so there's a part of this that
is that right wingers want to protect
the established industry of oil and gas
both for its own sake
and to anger liberals and they see
electric vehicles as a threat to fossil
fuels and that's true electric vehicles
are a threat to fossil fuels and that's
a good thing uh you also have you know
the the toyota prius specifically
has become a sort of emblem uh a pro
a microcosm
of what the right doesn't like right
wingers often see the prius as a very
beta energy vehicle they see it as a
form of left-wing virtue signaling now
the reality is we are very much beyond
that you can get i mean put tesla aside
you can get a porsche electric vehicle
uh volkswagen audi hyundai
what's more alpha than a ford f-150
electric which
is sold out until who knows when but the
stereotype remains and it conflicts with
what right-wingers like
you've then got the range issue or the
supposed issue
the right-wingers sort of idealizing the
great american road trip they say well
on my electric vehicle i can only go
250 miles on a charge or 275 or 300 or
330 or 370 or soon to be over 400 but
who actually drives that long without
stopping
i mean seriously like if you just on a
normal road trip even if you can fill
your tank with 500 miles worth of
gasoline
who's really driving a full four or 500
miles when's the last time you drove 300
miles without stopping it's not really
an impediment to the great american road
trip the right thinks things that the
left likes must be bad things and since
the left
generally speaking likes electric
vehicles the right ends up having to say
that they are bad and
it is a very strange thing
because when you actually go point by
point
they should be loving these electric
vehicles oh and by the way i shouldn't
forget
the electric vehicles don't make the big
boy vroom vroom engine noise
and i think that that's something that
right wingers also don't like so by all
accounts this is something that they
should embrace if they were paying
attention to their principles the
principles go in the toilet as soon as
they conflict with what's politically
convenient and that's exactly what we're
seeing right now
by the way
speaking going now from electric
vehicles to climate change more broadly
we've talked before about this it's
snowed in winter so climate change must
be made up we've talked about that idea
before we've heard it often on fox news
many right-wingers love to point out
when it's cold in winter somewhere
it must disprove
climate change part of which is record
high temperatures during certain parts
of the year well tucker carlson is
throwing his hat into the ring on this
tucker carlson in a segment during which
he blurts out a string of lies
um seems to say that the existence of
winter disproves climate change the
these people do you think they even
believe this stuff themselves but
they're not laughing anymore
the europeans have discovered that the
real threat to human civilization is not
global warming it never was global
warming the real threat to people
is global cooling otherwise known as
winter ah far more people freeze to
death every year than die of heat in
2019 for example four times as many
people died of cold
as if heat now you that if you have been
watching the show
you know i already debunked that about a
month ago and we'll get back to those
numbers in a moment
that's according to the institute for
health metrics and evaluation so when
temperatures in europe begin to drop a
few months from now this is right
because it's winter huge problem and
that will be obvious to everyone it's
not global warming it's global cooling
that's what's going to kill your
grandmother
and when everyone understands that
perfectly well a lot of things are going
to happen the status quo quo will
crumble
factories will close unemployment will
rise disposable income will disappear
it's going to be an economy crushing
dystopia
as soon as all of that happens now much
of what tucker carlson is saying is just
wrong and i know intuitively
maybe that's obvious but let's talk
about it let's talk about
what kills more heat or cold
heat kills more than cold
um if you look globally right i mean
we're we're a planet here we have an
earth as donald trump we have a world as
donald trump once said
way more people on earth
have the ability to heat their
environment when it's cold than the
number that have the ability to cool
their environment when it's hot in other
words more people have heat than air
conditioning
heat related death over time more than 5
million people die each year globally
because of excessively hot or cold
conditions okay
the heat related deaths continue to
climb
if you ask the question which kills more
extreme heat or extreme cold
you look at the data from noah
and noah has found that on average in
the united states there's
134 heat related deaths versus 30 cold
related deaths on i believe that's a per
capita adjusted number so tucker carlson
is wrong about what he's saying
now
maybe
you think tucker can't possibly be this
stupid no one could possibly be this
stupid and he's saying these things
knowing that they're not true well that
may absolutely be true he may just be
lying
it's still really bad for him to tell
those lies but he may just be lying and
it is stunning you know he talks about
europe it's very popular to make fun of
europe if you're an american
right-winger
europe
by and large understands and accepts the
science on this stuff
and they look at the american right wing
and they say what the hell is wrong with
people i understand wanting lower taxes
i even understand wanting less
regulation all things being equal but
denying the science of climate change
that doesn't make any sense and indeed
it doesn't indeed it doesn't he may be
just lying but it's still really bad
we'll have that tucker clip on our
instagram which you can find at david
pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
today we're going to be speaking with
dan cannon who's a civil rights lawyer
and a law professor at the university of
louisville he's also author of the book
pleading out how plea bargaining creates
a permanent criminal class dan really
great having you on i appreciate your
time hi david thanks for having me so i
mean i think maybe to start it would it
would make sense to talk about how this
sort of like a plea deal industrial
complex started i think many of us
intuitively know just because you've
been charged with a crime doesn't mean
that there will eventually be a trial
and a verdict in the way that we watch
sometimes on television in major trials
how did this develop that many cases
don't make it to trial whose motive who
was motivated to make that the reality
sure and i would i would go so far as to
say um almost all cases don't make it to
trial where we're sitting at right now
is a 97 plea bargain rate which is you
know just to sort of grasp the the how
big that is
um you know that's that's three out of
every
out of every 100 criminal cases that
might go to trial right you know on
average and that's the entire country
this is way way way far beyond what
anybody else is doing in the rest of the
world the rest of the world you know
even in incomparable
legal systems places like the united
kingdom and canada and so on i mean the
highest you get is to 80 and even that
is kind of extreme so nobody does it as
much as we do and and what the result
has been
pretty much the death of the jury trial
all together for all intents and
purposes the community has been
completely removed from processes of
criminal justice
and if you look historically at
how and why this originated you know
this uniquely american thing that we do
you got to go back all the way to the
beginning of the 19th century
and look at the early labor movement in
the united states and when that was
gathering steam that is at the same time
that that is the same time that the plea
bargain sort of took off in new england
right so you have this post-industrial
revolution situation where the working
classes are getting bigger and bigger
and bigger and bigger and up until 1830
you know plea bargaining was taboo there
was i mean you would see prosecutors
actually get prosecuted for
um trying to make deals with defendants
in the way that they do now so it was
completely off the table and and just
wasn't happening or if it was happening
we didn't know about it
then in massachusetts you see that
number tick up um very quickly by the
1850s it's 50 of all criminal cases are
ending in a a guilty plea
by the 1880s it's 88
right so almost all uh criminal cases
are ending in a guilty plea by the end
of the 19th century in massachusetts
and what's happening there is that
there's this this giant explosion of
working-class people right and at the
beginning in the 1830s the courts and
every other american institution is
working really really hard to break the
back of organized labor you've got uh
the first strikes are happening um in
the 1820s and then the first uh
federation of labor unions happens in
new york in 1834
and so the ruling classes are sort of
panicking and coming trying to figure
out you know how to how to fix this
whole thing first thing they start doing
is prosecuting groups of workers under
conspiracy statutes
so you get big groups of them at a time
and say all right you know you're going
to get together and try to get higher
wages or you know
shorter work days or something like that
and we're going to prosecute you for a
conspiracy
and it becomes pretty apparent
early on that that's that's not going to
work by the 1840s they've sort of
scrapped that whole idea because there's
just too many of them and
there's this the working classes are
getting too big and there's
working-class people for the first time
sitting on these criminal juries
so the response of the ruling classes at
that time as i as i talk about my book
is to number one take a lot of power
away from juries juries are not nearly
as powerful now as they were back then
and the other one is to introduce the
plea bargain so what that allows them to
do is to quickly and quietly prosecute
lots of individual workers one by one
rather than trying to smack a whole
bunch of them at a time with the
the hammer of the criminal law which
they knew that wasn't going to work they
were just too outnumbered
in the modern era
what is the advantage we'll talk first
about the prosecutors i mean it seems
if everybody went to trial they would
not have nearly the workforce that would
be required to try that number of cases
right i mean it just seems like an
impossibility yeah yeah so what you see
in situations where the in the few
situations where um you've actually
reduced the number of plea bargains is
that it does force prosecutors to make
tough decisions okay
so you look at the historical example of
alaska for a very brief period of time
in alaska you had an attorney general
come in and say
you know this is uh we're going to stop
doing plea bargaining we're going to
reduce the number of plea bars like all
the plea bargains are going to come
through me yep and and what i've heard
since i was in law school is that if
somebody does something like that it's
going to crash the whole system right
we're just not going to have a criminal
justice system anymore because the
wheels of justice are going to stop
turning and you know all these jury
trials are going to make it to where we
just can't do anything right but that's
not true if you look at the historical
example of alaska and some of these
other places where this has happened
what happened in alaska was uh
lots more cases went to trial um but the
system didn't crash it adapted and it
got more intelligent so at the point in
time in um alaska where this new
attorney general took over
the alaskan prosecutors were rejecting
about four percent of all the cases that
police brought to them so cops would
come in with a case and if it was a bad
case if it was a good case it didn't
matter because the prosecutors knew that
they could push somebody into some kind
of plea bargain and and get a conviction
right
taking plea bargaining off the table
means that the prosecutors have to be
more selective and so what happens right
off the bat is that the prosecutors go
from rejecting four percent of all those
cases to rejecting 40 percent
um so that forces prosecutors to to make
decisions right to to come up with
priorities for what they're going to
prosecute and what they're really you
know what the community's
priorities really are
um
and and so far from crashing the system
it adapts it becomes more intelligent
the prosecutors are making more
intelligent decisions and that forces
the police to cross their t's and dot
their eyes and do more diligent um
homework so if you think about the
situation that we have now you know
police know they're gonna get a
conviction they know that they're gonna
you know they
out of
most of the 11 million arrests that
happen in the united states every year
are going to result in some kind of
conviction
um and so they don't have to
have any real evidence that a crime was
committed they don't have to you know uh
they're not anticipating that they're
ever going to be put on the stand
uh or have to account for
the charges that they've levied against
somebody in any sort of meaningful way
um and and if you reduce the number of
plea bargain cases even just by a little
bit
that whole situation starts to change
because police know that the case is
more likely to go to trial and so they
have to be more careful in what they
bring to prosecutors in the first place
now from the standpoint of the
defendants the accused i think many of
us have this instinct that if we were
ever in such a situation and we felt
that we were innocent we would fight to
the end and demand a jury trial and so
on and so forth what are the incentives
that are there for those who are charged
to end up taking plea deals well it's
every incentive in the world isn't it
you know so so that's what we've decided
to do in the united states that's so
different from the rest of the world
here we've decided that we're going to
give every carrot and every stick to
prosecutors so they can end up with a
conviction somehow right
so
and this was all still sorting itself
out by the late 20th century
and then there was this supreme court
case called borden kercher versus hayes
where you have right down the road here
in lexington kentucky you've got
a 29 year old black horse transporter
who
gets picked up for trying to cash a bad
check worth 88 dollars right so he
writes a bad check
prosecutor comes to him says well it
looks like you were in trouble 10 years
ago over something and so
what you're going to do is for this 88
check you're going to take five years in
prison
and paul hey says i don't want to take
five years in prison prosecutor says
well if you don't take five years in
prison
then i'm going to hit you with this
habitual offender charge and that
carries a mandatory penalty of life in
prison
and that
he's like i don't want to do life in
prison over an 88 check but that's the
kind of power the prosecutor has
we're still sort of sorting out whether
or not we wanted to do that um in that
case paul hayes
didn't want to take the deal he went to
trial got convicted and got a life
sentence
and that case went all the way up to the
supreme court the supreme court at that
time in 1978 essentially says yeah you
know it's the prosecutor's job to
persuade a defendant to give up their
right to trial and they can do that by
hook or by crook they can do whatever
they want to get a defendant to to to
plead guilty and to forego the as the
prosecutor says the inconvenience of the
trial
um and so that case sort of throws the
floodgates open
uh for prosecutors to use anything and
everything that they want so you know if
you have um if you're charged with
murder let's say
um you know the prosecutor can offer
carrots can say look you know uh we're
going to bust these charges down to a
wanton endangerment
and you're going to do six months
probation because i just don't want to
take it to trial and i don't think it's
a very good case but i need a conviction
so you know take it or leave it and
you'd be hard-pressed to say i'm going
to leave that on the table right
conversely if a prosecutor wants to
proceed as though it is a death penalty
case
and threaten a defendant with literal
death if they don't take
a plea bargain to let's say life without
prison
they can do that too and in fact when
you look at the numbers one of the more
chilling statistics that i've got in my
book is that since the 1970s 75 percent
of the people on death row
could have avoided a death sentence by
taking the plea offer that the
prosecutor gave to them so in other
words the prosecutor has the power to
say you know if you don't take this deal
i'm going to put the death sentence on
the table it's not on the table until
you take until you say yes or no but if
you make me go to trial well death
penalty is on the table so you know
prosecutors just had this enormous power
to alter the legal landscape in any
given case that in the united states
that they just don't have in other
countries
is it easier for wealthier defendants to
avoid taking plea deals in the sense
that all else being equal
a long trial costs more money
sure
for for for reasons that i said before
it's long trials cost more money but
they're also you know uh more high
profile
right they're they're they're more
visible to the public uh the media pays
more attention to what's going on in
these high-profile cases so you get
somebody like a jeffrey epstein that's
gonna come in with you know it's it
quite obviously is is is guilty but
comes in with a team
of you know a hundred high paid lawyers
that are gonna make the prosecution work
uh for for anything that they end up
with
and so the prosecutor starts to look at
that situation saying all right this is
going to be very time consuming it's
going to be very difficult it's going to
be very expensive and it could be very
humiliating if we lose right you know
this is this this could have political
consequences and all this other stuff um
and it's going to be very much in the
public eye
so rather than go through you know the
the hoops of a trial
let's try to get them into a place where
they're going to take a plea and in fact
that is exactly what happened down in
florida with jeffrey epstein and the the
initial uh disastrous prosecution that
feds tried to carry on there
and and the victims were completely cut
out of that prosecution and epstein got
a slap on the wrist for you know
abhorrent conduct
and that is the kind of treatment that
that the wealthy typically can expect to
receive in the united states so when
people talk about there being two
different justice systems here that's
that's what they mean it seems the other
component to this also is the use of
pre-trial detention and the ability to
make bail i mean as a very general
concept i think it's probably more
difficult to mount a defense
all else being equal if you are being
detained up until the time of your trial
rather than out can can you talk a
little bit about that and the effect of
pretrial detention and possibly the
unequal application of pre-trial
detention on the sort of plea bargain
chances i guess
sure so cash bail like the plea bargain
is one of those things that we've
carried forward you know from an overtly
classist system in the 19th century
until now
right so you know it's yet another gun
that a prosecution that the prosecution
can put to a defendant's head to say
like listen you know if you don't take
this deal you're just going to stay
locked up there until we have a trial
and that could be two years from now
that could be three years from now so if
you can't post bail tough luck there you
sit in the county jail and these county
jails as i'm sure you know are are
oftentimes not friendly places they're
so unfriendly in fact especially
metropolitan jails are so unfriendly
that you see defendants taking deals
where they end up going to prison just
because prisons are a little friendlier
than the county jail right for example
you see that a lot
um
but but basically it's it's this arsenal
of tools that the prosecution has um
cash bail being one of them to make sure
that some that that every defendant gets
pressed into taking a deal of some kind
i had a uh client that i represented in
a civil rights case who insisted on his
innocence in uh in these criminal
charges that were levied against him way
out in rural kentucky
and
he sat there in jail waiting for his
trial to come up for three years well
the maximum sentence that he could have
come up with
that he he could have been subjected to
was only two years wow on the original
charges so he sits there in three years
waiting for his trial and then goes to
trial and no police show up and they
dismiss the charges
you know um and and so that is the kind
of thing that for people that insist on
their right to trial they're going to
get punished for it it's what we call
the trial penalties what happened to
paul hayes it's what's happened to
countless clients that i've had and it's
what happens all over america every
single day in those situations um i
think this was an issue with with
donziger in fact when the strictest
penalty you could get
is less than the time that you've been
detained pre-trial
is there some recourse or remedy in
those cases well you'd think there would
be right you'd think that and and that's
that was you know the case with my guy
down in eastern kentucky yeah
but the federal courts are so hostile uh
in most of the country to these civil
rights actions
that you're not very likely to get
anyway and especially since this is such
a common thing like for people to stay
in jail way longer than they should stay
in jail for one reason or another yeah
um that you know most most of those
folks that have been aggrieved by
something like that in the system
can't even find a civil lawyer to
represent them to to certain to
vindicate their rights certainly not in
rural parts of the country where this
happens all the time and when they do
find someone to represent them the civil
rights actions tend to fall flat on
their face because you've got these uh
judges that are hostile to these kinds
of actions to begin with right
the book is pleading out how plea
bargaining creates a permanent criminal
class we've been speaking to the book's
author law professor dan cannon dan
thank you so much for your time thanks
so much for having me
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind-the-scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com david
pakman show so it does seem as though
we're getting to the end stage of donald
trump's complete and total derangement
over the 2020 election we are just what
eight weeks seven and a half weeks
roughly from the 2022 midterms and
donald trump is now demanding that he be
made the president immediately or that a
new 2020 presidential election be held
this is obviously something only
somebody who is very sick could even
think of demanding donald trump of
course posting this to his pr platform
truth social truth essential uh a
platform which is having its fair share
of trouble which we will get to in a
moment donald trump posting yesterday
and this is real this is bottom of the
barrel stuff guys quote so now it comes
out conclusively
that the fbi buried the hunter biden
laptop story before the election knowing
that if they didn't trump would have
easily won the 2020 presidential
election this is massive fraud and
election interference at a level never
seen before in our capital c country
remedy
declare the rightful winner trump means
make me president or and this would be
the minimal solution declare the 2020
election irreparably compromised and
have a new capital e election
immediately
he seems to be saying
that the fbi not helping him as he sees
it
is some kind of election fraud tampering
or interference and by the way the fbi
sort of did tip the scales for trump in
the first election that he won i mean
think back to 2016.
james comey already did a press
conference about the hillary email stuff
it was a closed subject
and then right before the election for
reasons that are still not clear james
comey comes out and does another press
conference about that very same
investigation even though there were not
charges forthcoming and hillary clinton
was not going to be charged with
anything
um
that is
the reality of the situation and think
how i i we're roughly it's funny we're
about 666 days since the presidential
election of 2020. it's just a
coincidence and i don't know if that's
tomorrow or the next day we're
roughly
it will be soon
666 days since the 2020 presidential
election
and donald trump wants to either be
reinstated
or wants a brand new election it says
likely that mike pillow
or eric trump are going to be put in the
oval office in the next two years as it
is trump is going to over 54 countries
have now been taken by the machines
exactly
remember this op-ed from november of
2020 it was written by mick mulvaney
remember mick mulvaney who for a while
was donald trump's chief of staff
and the subject was
if he loses
trump will concede gracefully he'll
fight hard to make sure the results are
fair
and in the end he'll accept the result
whatever it is that was mick mulvaney
writing in november of 2020 specifically
november 7th of 2020
how humiliating is this how long is it
going to go and i know that we all joked
around we had sort of a good time even
though it was like laughing to avoid
crying
saying
when it was
february of 2021 when it was april of
2021 we joked around and we said wow how
long are they going to keep doing this
how
are they going to go all the way up to
the 2022 midterms talking about
reinstatement and trump continues to
talk about it and mike pillow continues
to talk about it and other hangers on
continue to talk about reinstatement
we are now getting to the november 22
midterm the question now is are they
going to keep talking about
reinstatement beyond the november 22
midterm which would be just another
level altogether it is wacky wacky stuff
and the next layer of trouble is that
the platform on which donald trump is
publishing these deranged tirades uh
is in very serious trouble let's talk
about that next
i have to admit when when i am taking
pleasure in someone else's misery i
admit it to you guys i do i don't hide
that
donald trump's truth social is
collapsing truth essential they owe more
than a million dollars to their web
hosting company and according to tom
buggione
for salon.com
the platform is rapidly heading for
bankruptcy i admit it i am taking
pleasure in this i am
donald trump's truth social
is facing some very serious financial
problems
they reportedly owe
the web hosting company that they use
more than a million dollars already
they are having problems with some of
their intellectual property uh trademark
uh registrations in a filing this week
digital world acquisition which planned
to take the trump media and technology
group public
is now issuing warnings about what the
future may bring isn't that sad
quote the company warned this week that
its businesses could be damaged if trump
becomes less popular or there are
further controversies that damages
credibility
the company has seen its stock price
plunged nearly 75 since its march peak
and reported in a filing last week it
lost
6.5 million dollars in the first half of
the year
the company's financial base has begun
to erode the trump company stopped
paying right forge a conservative web
hosting service in march and now owes it
more than a million dollars
this is a i'm going to tell you guys
this is a delightful fate
and i have to tell you
i'm not taking pleasure in this
because i want some authoritarian
censorship of the platform i'm taking
pleasure in it because it's the free
market deciding the platform is so lame
no one cares it's not popular producer
pat mentioned on the bonus show
yesterday that many people have accounts
only to be able to see what other people
are posting not because they want to
post anything just because you have to
have an account at last we checked in
order to see the things that are posted
here's a report from msnbc about this
former president trump's social media
platform is facing money problems right
now truth social doesn't have a
guaranteed source of income and it
doesn't get any it could go bust a new
sec filing from the company planning to
take truth social public is warning of
damages to the already slowing business
if the former president
becomes less popular or there are
further controversies that damage his
credibility
now this comes as the platform has
reportedly stopped paying its web
hosting service and now owes it more
than one million dollars this according
to fox business let's bring in nbc news
senior reporter ben collins uh and
here's why we're bringing in ben because
you're an expert on the internet this is
really the best so my first question is
just how popular or not popular
is truth social me does the former
president have reason to be concerned
yes
it's not popular at all let's be real
about this uh donald trump is the
primary user on that platform and even
he only gets a few thousand
uh likes or what they call them
re-truths per post there true his
website exists so it can be screenshoted
and posted onto bigger platforms
facebook and twitter places that he has
been banned from he wants to be able to
tweet this is his way to tweet all right
anyway so i think you guys get what's
going on um this this is a
what's great about this is
the right lives in an imaginary world
and one of the totally fantasy world
beliefs that the right has constructed
about social media
obviously that right-wingers are being
overwhelmingly censored and depressed by
the
jack-booted uh
terms of service moderators or whatever
the case may be but also that there's
just massive demand from right-wingers
for a so-called free speech platform and
that as soon as one is available they're
going to flock to it right away twitter
was copied over into truth truth central
it's just a clone it looks just like
twitter they just copied it so when it
comes to the functionality you would
think that if there was really such
demand that wouldn't be an impediment to
people going over the truth
but people aren't doing it and it's
because there isn't actually demand for
that i hope that it fails and it seems
to be going in that direction
yesterday
i told you about republican senator
lindsey graham threatening riots if
donald trump is indicted
infowars conspiracy theorist alex jones
who by the way
really doesn't like me thank your lucky
stars every day you're not dave pagman i
know he doesn't like me alex jones is
now joining in with mega world in
predicting violence now as always his
predictions are more specific take a
listen to this
the next 71 days we're going to see some
very violent fireworks
i would predict
racially motivated mass shootings
bombings
poisonings
we're going to see poisonings and
bombings he says attacks on power
supplies being blamed on the right wing
they intend to bring in a full
dictatorship in the next 71 days who
will be the dictators
and we are all strapped to this thing
this is such a dangerous time and i
would advise the globalists
who are mid-level that think they're
about to have a leftist revolution i
like that mid-level globalists if you're
a high-level globalist or a low-level
globalist you don't have to worry
globalist internationalist trotskyite
socialist shun like obama trudeau macron
and the rest of these zio beasts
yeah all right last few seconds
globalists don't actually plan at the
higher levels to have that they plan on
having a civil war that brings down
america and you'll be the fall guy right
very very scary stuff now i do wonder
if there's a donation maybe of 29.99 to
alex jones that might help stop the
globalists i don't know is it more
upsetting honestly
is it more upsetting that alex jones
says this stuff
or is it more upsetting that some people
believe it or is it more upsetting that
some people believe it so much that then
they donate money as a result which of
those three things is the most
disturbing and this is very similar to
yesterday's segment on lindsey graham it
sounds to me
like alex jones
is predicting
that trumpists are going to do all these
things but he's incentivized to make it
look like they're not really trumpists
if they do it because remember he said
there's going to be bombings and there's
going to be poisonings and there's going
to be attacks on our uh water supplies
you know different what did he say power
sources
and it's going to be blamed
on the right
he already is preemptively you know he
just got dinged almost 50 million
for
lies related to supposed false flags and
he's already out there doing his false
flag dog and pony show again it's quite
a wild situation but there's alex joins
joi alex jones joining in
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
here is an individual who called in
very very confused about my family
background listen to this
hi david so i can't help but notice that
you're jewish and from argentina that's
true so far beautiful
do you have a family history
that
has ties to germany
no like did you are you from argentina
because your family escaped the
holocaust and uh fled to argentina along
with a lot of other people who did that
well yes to some degree not from germany
uh
on my
basically
three of my four grandparents had
families that went to argentina
well before world war ii
one grandparent went to argentina from
poland very very close to world war ii
but nothing germany related uh from
germany and if so
um did is that part of your motivation
for doing the show is to fight back
against fascism and
nazi ideology uh that the trump
administration is bringing back to the
mainstream well yeah i mean listen
yes
part of the reason for doing this show
is to fight against right-wing
authoritarianism
uh fascism etc but because i think those
things are bad
not because my family is from germany so
certainly some elements in that
voicemail that are mildly tethered to
reality but the big picture
not not quite so much but i still
appreciate the opportunity to clarify
folks the member town hall is tomorrow
night 6 p.m eastern wednesday august
31st member town hall okay oh the bonus
show or you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
is bad yes when you become a member at
joinpakman.com
you get access to the bonus show
and you also get invited to participate
in the members only town halls it will
be streaming live for everybody on
youtube twitch and facebook tomorrow at
6 pm eastern but the participants will
be limited to our website members you
can become a member in mere moments by
signing up at joinpackman.com we've got
a great bonus show for you today
uh buoyed by a number of different
legislative accomplishments and a rising
approval rating
joe biden is going to give a prime time
speech to the nation about the soul of
the united states on thursday evening in
philadelphia i will be covering it live
in prime time we will talk about that
speech and the timing on the bonus show
we will also talk about the launch of
nasa's giant moon rocket which has sadly
been delayed after an engine issue
uh i was looking forward to this we will
talk about it on the bonus show and
pennsylvania democratic senate candidate
john fetterman is calling on joe biden
to move towards decriminalizing
marijuana ahead of uh biden's visit to
pennsylvania on thursday which i agree
with we will talk about all of those
things and more when i am joined by
producer pat on today's bonus show
get instant access by signing up at
joinpacman.com
otherwise we'll be back tomorrow with a
brand new show